تسلم السلطه للشعب بدون لف ولا دوران
رسائل تتوالى من قاده الدعم السريع في
بريد السلطه العسكريه القائمه تؤكد ان
الخلافات لم تهدا او تحل هذه المره جاءت
التلميحات المبطنه من القائد الثاني لقوات
الدعم السريع عبد الرحيم والسبب هو قتل
المتظاهرين الرجل الذي يعتبر احد قاده
المنظومه الامنيه وجه انتقادا وكذلك
تهديدا بانهم لن يسمحوا باعتقال السياسيين
مره اخرى من الليله
وصاعدا بعد موت الشهيد ربنا يرحمه لن نسمح
باي قد الشباب المتظاهرين ولن نسمح باي
احتقان للسياسيين
تحالف الحريه والتغيير والقوى الموقعه على
الاتفاق الاطري ينظرون بقلق ويستشعرون خطر
الاتهامات المتبادله بين الجيش والدعم
السريع لكن في ذات الوقت يبدو ان تصريحات
الدعم السريع هي الاقرب لموقفهم السياسي
ومع ذلك يظل السؤال الاهم والمطروح من
قبلهم عن جدول عمليه السياسيه الحاليه
الذي نراه الان هو تطور مهم نحن نرحب به
هنالك تحديات تواجه العمليه السياسيه من
ضمنها
الممارسات التي حدثت في الايام الماضيه ضد
المتظاهرين هذه تعوق العمليه السياسيه
وهذه تناقض روح الاتفاق الايطالي وبالتالي
هذه التحديات يعني تختبر صدق وجديه كل
الاطراف الموقعه لاتفاق الاطار على راسها
الجانب العسكري يرى العسكر والمدنيون ان
تسليم السلطه للشعب هو افضل الحلول لهذه
الازمه لكن كيف يتم ذلك مع تباين واضح
بينهما طالما هو نطق بكلمه بدون لف او
دوران انا اعتقد انها هي مفتاح الحل لكل
المشاكل هو تسليم السلطه للشعب بدون لف او
دوران بدون لف او دوران يعني تسليمها
بصوره فوريه بدلا من انتظار عمليه سياسيه
تلكات كثيرا وتاخرت كثيرا خلال الفتره
والشهور الماضيه ما انتهدا التصريحات
والرد عليها بين قوات الدعم السريع والجيش
حتى تعود مره اخرى لتفتح باب التساؤلات
على مصراعيه ما يجعل الوضع السياسي
السوداني على صفيح ساخن سالم الهاشمي
العربيه الخرطوم